there is always like a part of you as an
actor who's new coming into a very
established thing
you know like if it doesn't work or you
don't quite nail it
like they might not want to bring you
back
i just remember being so nervous like
all of these actors i just watched most
of my life and
my very first scene was this scene where
i basically
call out every single person i'd pretty
much hardly met anybody
other than vin really why would you
trust us
you barely know us i know enough
ex-cop military something like that
the way you took out them guys shows
training
tech guy offended by the hacker remark
naturally
alpha mrs alpha
joker i definitely had a pretty out of
body kind of experience but really
exciting and everyone were like you're
one of us now it's you're good it's fine
and it kind of went smoothly every time
you have the first day and you're with
everybody
it's like everything you just like want
to hug everyone it's like oh hi
like it's exciting and ramsay has
evolved with every movie and become more
and more integral to the team
so i'd like to think that that is
because you know i
bought something that fans really enjoy
she's impressive
so she she doesn't feel intimidated by
these people so
even though i was secretly like